[Music]
foreign
we work with a lot of students and from
university schools and colleges hosting
them here as well as exposing them to
what we call ecological entrepreneurship
but then also
training them in the mindset that is
required to be an entrepreneur in a
context like Kashmir
[Music]
the context over the last few decades
especially you know the things that have
happened here the social context has
conditioned people to look for security
rather than creativity so
entrepreneurship here needs a new
approach
[Music]
the food is delicious nice to eat
something that actually comes from the
farm to your table we believe in
integrating all our human needs so we
have food we have Recreation we have
play area we have spaces for kids we
have spaces for younger people for older
people the idea is to design a place
design a lifestyle for everybody
thank you
[Music]
the ecological the cultural wisdom in
any place is a resource so this can be
replicated anywhere and everywhere
[Music]